it's a voyage that began only a few
weeks ago in southern mexico
but for seven members of mexico's
zapatista army of national liberation
it's a journey 500 years in the making
after traveling one thousand kilometers
over land they prepared a small flotilla
of canoes for a transatlantic voyage
the delegation is codenamed squadron 421
and their mission is a symbolic conquest
of europe
we want to learn more how these other
worlds are we want to listen we want to
share
we want to find out how it is so we can
learn
in the mexican capital supporters of the
militant socialist collective known
as the zapatistas gathered to wish safe
travels to the would-be conquerors
this is a trip that has its first stop
in europe and includes a visit to 30
countries
the intention is to also arrive in other
continents
after leading a brief armed rebellion in
1994 in southern mexico
the zapatistas have often been
characterized as a militant
separatist group though the collective
has since evolved into more of a
political organization that places an
emphasis
on the rights of indigenous people
activists say they hope demonstrations
like these will dispel rumors about the
zapatista rebel collective
and teach more people about the history
of mexico's revolutionary movements
organizers here in mexico city
encouraged demonstrators
to build their own paper boats a gesture
that both symbolizes the first arrival
of spanish conquistadors and the
returned voyage by sapatista activists
now five centuries later
as the seven member armada of sapatista
conquistadors
prepared to set sail for the old world
they were cheered on by indigenous
activists
they are in the fight in the resistance
and so are we
we believe a different world is possible
[Music]
event organizers say beyond the symbolic
conquest
they hope this action will help inspire
global awareness for environmental and
social
progress through a more open dialogue
between cultures
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city